my advice to young people is you never
want to do something on the spur of the
moment and if you say no me me me III
nobody likes you anybody that tries to
centralize everything through themselves
or through their staff really is making
a terrible mistake you can't control how
lucky you are although the more you work
the lucky you get you can't just say
something and believe it you have to be
able to show people that you're right
the most important asset you have of the
people that leave at night and come in
in the morning I just don't have
anything in common with people that sit
there and say oh my god it was terrible
you're going to spend your entire life
doing something different than what you
think should have would have been could
have is not a particularly useful thing
to spend your time doing this is a world
and I think it's good where you don't do
anything by yourself he's an American
business magnate politician and
philanthropist he served as a 108th
mayor of New York City serving for three
consecutive terms with a net worth of
forty 1 billion dollars he's a seventh
richest person in United States he's
Michael Bloomberg and here his top ten
rules for success you know I think it's
very my advice to young people is you
never want to do something on the spur
of the moment you don't want to jump too
quickly that doesn't mean you should sit
around and waste your whole life and
never realize when something's not going
to happen or when the opportunity's not
going to be presented but every time I
thought about leaving Salomon I stopped
stopped and said you know I'm learning a
lot and even though I might have been
able to make more money elsewhere it was
a great firm they were scrupulously
honest phenomenally competent worked
very hard very nice to me and I always
decided to stay I don't think I ever
seriously other than maybe a little
walter mitty dream now and then I think
of a seriously ever thought of leaving
and it turned out to be great I can say
nothing but good things about them even
when I'm firing me was the right thing
you never wanted to beat your
competition no I want to be successful
used to teammates versus competition
right yeah but but I mean I'd saw them
brothers all as times I you work with
other people one of the
is instantly Stephanie to really get
ahead is to give credit to somebody else
when I say oh I didn't do it Lloyd did
that and he involved me let me tell you
I'm telling everybody it's me as well
but I've now made a friend and you
respect me because I've shared the
credit and if you say no me me me III
nobody likes you and nobody respects you
and they think you are exaggerating
everything but to the extent you give
credit Dale's was the thought of a lot
are they exaggerating doesn't even come
up and I'm a big delegator in terms of a
management style if you're going to run
a 20-7 24/7 organization you have to do
that anybody that tries to centralize
everything through themselves or through
their staff really is making a terrible
mistake
but that's why lots of businesses don't
work and once why lots of governments
don't work because they do exactly that
the only thing that you can control that
influences success in life is how hard
you work how honest you are and how well
you deal with others you can control
those variables but those variables it
you can't control how lucky you are
although the more you work the lucky you
get you have no influence on the
intellectual capabilities that God did
or did not give you but you can work as
hard as possible you can be scrupulously
honest so that people respect you and
you can get along with others because
nobody does anything by themselves did
you have to pay a price though you
personally well I think that everything
is an either-or you there is a price in
everything you can study or you can go
out and play you can defer to others or
you can try to hog the credit you can be
honest and suffer the consequences or
you can lie cheat and steal and
short-term maybe even advance but
long-term you are better off if you'll
work harder you are better off if you're
honest then you are better off if you
give others credit and get them to help
you with by helping them what do you
tell others who try to strike that
balance between family and work and
I think the answer of either/or is
invariably yes you can't go all in one
direction you cannot walk away from your
family for your career on the other hand
if you walk away from your career from
your career for your family you're not
going to have the money to support the
family and parents all the time are
making those kinds of choices between
career and family they do some of both
and you try to blend the two and that
may not be the perfect answer but that's
a practical answer that I've always told
young people when they go off to college
you have to study and you have to get
good grades but you certainly should
have a good time as well because that's
part of your growing up experience and
there's no point in leading life to
suffer all the time you want to enjoy
life as well as the next person so it's
some balance some blend between the two
I went to Hopkins to study physics and
it turned out there was a German
requirement so after 30 days I became an
engineer where there was no language
requirement and I think looking back an
engineering background was perhaps the
transformative thing in my life because
in science and it would have worked if I
stayed as physicist who as opposed in
science you have to be able to look in a
mirror and answer the question you can't
just say something and believe it you
have to be able to show people that
you're right the essence of science is
that somebody else independently can
verify what you claimed you saw and that
discipline of not just taking people's
word for it or not just automatically
falling into what's generally accepted
has forced me to step back and say why
and to question and if you question why
we're doing things I think you'll find
yourself targeting your energies much
more efficiently appropriately and much
more in a much more satisfying way so
somebody says well the
works well that may be but you know stop
and think does it make any common sense
you listen to what people are telling
you to do think about what they say in
the newspaper does it make any sense do
you want to be part of it could you do
it better so it's that mental discipline
of questioning which I guess is the
scientific method what do you think has
mattered about the culture of Bloomberg
and what lessons do you think a company
like this should learn I think it's not
just the companies I think it's the
government's and everybody else people
want recognition and respect and whether
you do it by giving them free food and
nice offices whether you do it by always
giving them the credit when somebody
says why does it go on I always make a
point when I walk into a building I
shake the hands of the security people
at the door if it wasn't for them the
rest of us wouldn't be able to go in and
conduct our business they're just as
important as the head of the company I
think we have too many distinctions
between people and the Galit aryan
concept that america was built around i
think really works and it's at bloomberg
i abolished all titles
there's no titles in the company on my
card it never said anything it just said
Michael Bloomberg and address and phone
number and in those days you need to
have email addresses today they continue
with that process everybody knows who
they work for there is a hierarchy
actually you have to have a hierarchy
you have to have structure but that
doesn't mean that we should have every
time we introduce somebody something
that distinguishes and has says that one
person is more important than the other
in city government you can't quite do
that because they've built into that the
structure is is different and the
requirements they use titles is
different but in the private sector to
the extent that you can include
everybody in this room and around
world that works for Google I would
argue do it that's what we do at
Bloomberg it's the extent that you can
make people be happy and to come to work
and want to be there in the end
luck plays a very important part and how
successful you are but the harder you
work and the longer you work the lucky
you're going to be so you want people to
want to come in early in the morning and
want to stay late you want people that
if they want to take some time off for
family obligations that's fine but you
want them to want to come back and I
think if you take a look you're never
going to please everybody Bloomberg has
about 9,500 employees maybe 120 offices
around the world and they'll always be
somebody that isn't happy but
fundamentally we have a very low
turnover rate and I think whenever you
have intellectual content as the basis
of your business and certainly Google
does and certainly Bloomberg does the
most important asset you have of the
people that leave at night and come in
in the morning and so that's what your
focus should be
then what's your advice to these small
business founders today we're card
you're going to need some luck but the
harder you work the luckier you get and
if it doesn't work out that's not the
end of the world I just don't have
anything in common with people that sit
there and say oh my god it was terrible
so it's over it's water over the dam
under the bridge get on with it and
start another business the next day or
another career and be honest look in a
mirror and say why didn't it work out
well it wasn't the skill set or it
wasn't I didn't have the temperament for
it or I was in the wrong place wrong
time maybe I can afford to do it again
maybe I can't but people aren't honest
with themselves they what I've always
done is I've taken a yellow pad I draw a
line down the middle write out the pros
on one side the cons on another in a
sense that if I let you see it you
wouldn't laugh at me and then when I get
done I just rip it up and throw it away
because I've worked out in my mind what
is real and what isn't and what I can
present to people and
camp and this goes back to my Boy Scout
days is be prepared I know what you're
thinking you're already prepared you've
mapped out the rest of your life the
rest of your education postgraduate work
residences residency residences
fellowships clerkships and you're going
to have a long meaningful career you
have all of your plans already laid down
that's not the preparation I am talking
about because let me tell you the
likelihood of you winding up ten years
from now doing what you think you're
going to be doing ten years from now is
probably less than one in ten the truth
of the matter is you don't know what
opportunities are going to be presented
to you you don't know where you're going
to succeed and where you're going to
fail the careers that you wind up in are
invariably going to be very different so
what I would do is I would focus on how
I interact with people how I approach
problems I would get involved in
government if you want to go into public
service I will recommend your first
become a billionaire but that's another
issue you're going to spend your entire
life doing something different than what
you think and the good news is that
Dartmouth is preparing you for that
because while you think there are
individual subjects what they're really
teaching you to do is to think and to
reason to build relationships and that's
what's going to carry you well from the
book afterward after you were fired or
let go from Salomon I didn't sit around
wondering what was happening at the old
firm I didn't go back and visit I never
look over my shoulder once finished gone
life continues yes you can't sit there
and should have would have been could
have is not a particularly useful thing
to spend your time doing it will just
they'll leave you heartsick or will
leave you living a past life and not
looking towards what could be great
tomorrow how how important is it to have
salesmanship you could have the better
like I don't know any business where
sales isn't a big part of it or
cooperation and collaboration isn't a
big part of it I suppose if you're among
them vows silence maybe but an author
for example you've got to work with an
editor you've got to talk to your
publisher and you have to deal with your
family
and it's there all this is a world and I
think it's good where you don't do
anything by yourself nobody just works
for one person or just works for
themselves nobody does anything
independently we deal and and with
whether it's your family your outside
life business life or whatever
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because we'll see ask me
too so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below see what I can do
I also love to know which of Michael
Bloomberg's top ten rules meant the most
to you it's going to have the biggest
impact on your life on your business
leave it in the comments I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe I'll see you soon
what would you like to see as your
legacy what is it that you would like to
say that you achieve with your life well
I think I want my kids to look back and
say he was a great mayor and honest and
made a big difference in the city but I
think the things that will last are
things like the life expectancy numbers
or the economic development of New York
City compared to other cities or
reforming education which is always a
two step forward one step back thing but
if we can be an impetus to Rahm Emanuel
for example to stand up and fight for
control of the school system in Chicago
or elsewhere around the country I think
those would be good legacies if we could
figure out a ways to stop this carnage
from illegal guns that would be another
thing but if you go back go down the
road and look back those the kinds of
things investment in educational
institutions my alma mater Johns Hopkins
that you're on the board of or Harvard
where a mic one of my daughter's went to
graduate school and I did or Princeton
or NYU those universities will I hope
make a difference in the world and I'll
be a little bit a little part of it at
Hopkins we have a malaria project for
example trying to build a better
mosquito and the reason you want a
mosquito that's tougher than the others
that doesn't carry the malaria parasite
and then it would drive out the others
it's really probably the only ways to
stop malaria which kills a couple
million people every year when our Nobel
Prize winner who runs the project wins
his second Nobel Prize and I've
challenged him to do so I have a little
bit of that prize because I helped fund
it and so will the his clinicians and
other scientists that work with them and
so will patients that work with them we
don't do anything on our own and
everybody collaborates and gets
something from somebody else and I also
hope that I will set a standard and that
whoever comes after me will be a better
mayor than I am I'm going to live in New
York City and I am always in my life
tried to hire people smarter than me
I've certainly done that with
my deputy mayor's in the city I've
certainly done that with the people that
are running Bloomberg and hopefully the
public will pick a successor that will
turn out to be nobody'll ever think
anybody is the beginning but always you
know will turn out to be a better mayor
and will take it forward I hope that
Washington gets its act together and
starts understanding we are in trouble
in this country and now Ferguson wrote a
great story about the end of
civilizations and how quickly things can
collapse Rome in a couple decades the
USSR in a couple of years I mean it was
the second biggest power in the world
and to use it's gone we really are on a
cliff and it's not just the fiscal cliff
we're going we're already over the
fiscal cliff the question is are we
going to pull a ripcord or just keep
falling but we're on a cliff socially as
well and the world is not necessarily on
our side
did you ever think your company wasn't
going to make it in the early years were
you nervous it wasn't going to make it
for the first well for the first year
it's always an exciting thing every two
weeks I wrote another check to the
company from my personal bank account to
put money in to pay the help and the
last year you could of the three that it
took me to get customers you could see
that that light at the end of the tunnel
wasn't a train coming towards you it
really was that you were going to get
out of this and was going to work the
middle year what you find is your family
and your friends say you know I know you
know what you're doing and I have all
that confidence in you but you know just
in case because we were competing
against big companies and every article
in paper said this is foolish you can't
win against big companies I've always
thought that competing against big
companies for a small company is not
only exciting it is it has enormous
potential because big companies never
believe little company is going to
challenge them until it's too late and
big companies have such an
infrastructure and investment product
and people and brands and that sort of
thing that they can't change and you
know clay Christensen is disruptive
technologies if you need more examples
of that taking place just pick up the
paper every day there's another industry
going out of business
I was the other day we get
Awards - 10 different small startup
companies our Economic Development
Corporation did in the fashion industry
and I'm talking to this guy what did he
get an award from he has a computer
program you just stand in front of his
camera turn around once and then he has
your body measurements - every single
square inch of your body down to a
science that goes straight to the loom
and the next piece Nick next set of
genes that comes off is built perfectly
for your body think about how many
people in the process that's going to
take out that's one of the great
challenges for creating new jobs that
that kind of technology takes away a lot
of the kinds of things but there is
still the demand for people creating
that kind of program there's still
demand for the designer who comes up
with what's fashionable or not so there
is potential but it requires investment
and infrastructure and it requires
better education than we are providing
our kids today with and it requires
people from around the world wanting to
come here rather than sending these
industries overseas